the World Cup frenzy is fully on in
Argentina but people are not only
anxious to see Lionel Messi on the field
they're also trying to feel their panini
sticker albums Luca Carrera comes to
this Plaza every weekend to try to find
missing stickers
it's hard to find all the stickers just
a few blocks away there is a kiosk that
sells packets of them I buy those and
then I come here to try to change them
The Young and the elderly get together
here to exchange stickers these are
informal swap meets happening because
they've been in short supply in recent
weeks the stickers have been a World Cup
tradition in Argentina for decades but
they have become very very difficult to
find and that's why hundreds and
hundreds of people are coming to plazas
like this one in Buenos Aires to try to
find the sticker they're missing experts
say the lack of stickers is due to
paninis in capacity to meet the demand
which is estimated to be up 40 since the
last World Cup
the reasons why vary but one of them
could be that it's likely to be Messi's
last World Cup and people here are
crazed at the possibility of him finally
lifting the trophy
the government was forced to intervene
and mediate between Panini and angry
shopkeepers who didn't have enough stock
to sell
disparate mothers come with their
children and they look at me and say
please tell me you have stickers I have
to say I don't my mother told me the
other day do you know what my son is
doing he's drawing in the pictures
himself he draws in Messi to say he has
the sticker the truth is it's terrible
it makes me feel bad
went from collecting the stickers to
selling them on the streets Argentina's
inflation rate is expected to reach a
hundred percent this year and she says
it's helping her pay the bills
I have a disabled daughter and this is
helping us financially we have fun
exchanging tickets we have failed our
album they are difficult to find but we
go to retailers and other places to try
to get them
this is the land of Diego Maradona and
Leonel Messi and passion for football
runs high here in a country ravaged by
inflation and crisis the stickers have
become an escape of the problems people
here face every day
Buenos Aires